okay how much time you got in etosha
because I'm about to tell you the entire
plot of your movie including all its big
surprise reveals for months before it
actually hits theaters who's the supreme
intelligence officer now
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show where two minutes of trailer
footage becomes 15 minutes of theory man
talk about a great 2019 for Scarlett
Johansson right she was nominated for
Best Actress in the super-depressing
marriage story she was nominated for
Best Supporting Actress for the old so
super depressing Jojo rabbit she had a
key role in the highest-grossing movie
of all time with endgame it also was in
Captain Marvel we did one year that's
for massive films to award nominations
and an equal number of on-screen deaths
I mean she is figuratively killing it
and movies in turn are literally killing
her and 2020 is just keeping her
momentum going as Marvel rewinds back in
time to tell a prequel story about the
iconic Natasha Romanov in their upcoming
movie Black Widow now can I just take a
moment to say how much I love the name
Black Widow for a deadly female spy I
mean everyone knows that a bite from a
black widow spider is unlikely to be
fatal and most of the over 2,000 bites
each year don't even need medical
attention what has everything I've ever
been told about spiders a lie I mean do
they even eat their husbands yes okay
but only in laboratories with unnatural
conditions even in Australia they've
only managed to rack up one death in 37
years
okay somethings tell me that black widow
spiders just have themselves a really
solid PR team so I guess in all fairness
the spider might not be all that deadly
but Natasha certainly is and based on
the trailers this new movie is gonna
expose to us a bit more about our
mysterious backstory the training
program that made her into the widow she
is today as well as other members of
their little bloody ballet squad but
there's one main question that the
newest trailer is just begging for us to
answer and that's the clip that I played
at the top of the video is that guy who
is our main villain who is the face
behind the mask based on outfit the
shield and past history with Black Widow
in the comics we know that it's gonna be
a character named taskmaster it'll get
to a bit more about him in a minute the
bigger question is who is under that
mask
in fact Marvel is so intent on keeping
the true identity of taskmaster such a
mystery that he doesn't even have a
confirmed actor yet which is very weird
for a company that's traditionally used
villain positions for stunt casting
I mean they've sent noted bad guys like
Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio or Josh
Brolin Santos out on the talk show
circuit to push their movies hard so why
why would they be
Oh tight-lipped about black widows main
villain well with this being a spy movie
it means that the reveal of who's under
that mask is gonna be a big twist for
the audience except here's the thing I
feel pretty darn confident I already
know the answer
scratch that I feel really confident I
know the answer the trailers are very
clearly trying to misdirect you about
who is behind that mask so today I'm
gonna look at the potential candidates
to bunk them all and then tell you the
reveal of Marvel's next massive
superhero hit months before it hits the
big screen what do you have to say about
that Scarlett Johansson are you one of
those people that goes online and then
you look at all the screen grabs you are
you're one of those people I'm not
judging you who are completely judging
me right now let's start by learning a
bit more about who this guy is and what
is traditional powerset consists of
taskmaster in Marvel Comics is usually a
guy by the name of Tony masters masters
has an ability called photographic
reflexes which is similar to having
photographic memory except that beyond
just recalling things with incredible
accuracy masters can accurately
reproduce the actions of anyone he sees
it's an incredibly cool power that makes
him a very difficult animated feat
considering he can just always counter
you with your own moves
he's like the ultimate uno reverse card
however his memory can be overwhelmed by
this ability so we'll often forget
simple things like the names of his
loved ones or who he used to work for
taskmaster is a mercenary and will work
for the highest bidder without a care
for their ideologies which means that
sometimes taskmaster is as much a good
guy as he is a bad guy he's worked for
pretty much everyone from shield to
Thunderbolt Ross who once you know it is
also gonna be in this movie and that's
far from all we know about this new
Marvel movie thanks to Natasha's
untimely demise and endgame
we know for sure that this movie is
gonna be a prequel the sentiments been
echoed by everyone working on the movie
Scarlett Johansson even gave us a more
specific timeframe for the majority of
the events of the plot it takes place
after this almost 9 before the infinity
war those all the words know he may have
missed a couple there world war one
world war two Vietnam War career war war
the roses for my personal favorites
spanish-american little cross-cultural
excitement going on there so in a
reflection of the comics and knowing
that Thunderbolt Ross is making an
appearance here
it's likely that the story of this new
black widow will at least in part
revolve around Ross hunting down Natasha
in the wake of her betrayal of Tony
Stark in the sokovia accords if you can
manage to remember that far back in the
series you remember when the government
was all like you superheroes are
dangerous and need to be supervised
Captain America was all like no man I'm
a rebel and Tony Stark was totally
you're right government you pay me a lot
in government contracts so I kind of
have to agree also for some reason I
grew a conscience because the story
demanded it and wouldn't you know it
while we were all distracted by
spider-man showing up Black Widow
was there apparently somewhere back
there cuz here if you squint you can see
kind of the black blur just flashing
across the screen yeah she's way back
there fighting the other guy who doesn't
have superpowers well anyway she had to
choose a side right she chose one but
then she ended up flip-flopping anyway
she went against Tony and the government
and so with this movie coming
canonically after civil war if it's
perfectly in the timeline that they'd
now be looking to track her down we also
know that at least some of its gonna
take place even earlier in Natasha's
career aside from flashbacks to her days
training in the program we can expect to
see at least part of the movie taking
place before Natasha joined shield in
the first place we know this because the
very opening shot of the trailer shows
the Liberty statue in Budapest if that's
not ringing any bells let's take a brief
trip even further back down memory lane
to the original Avengers movie so we
know that at least at some point in this
movie they're gonna be in Budapest place
where Hawkeye and Natasha have a long
history we also know from that same
movie that they met because Hawkeye was
ordered to kill Natasha but Clint ended
up ignoring the order and recruiting her
instead I got on shields radar
agent Barton was sent to kill me he made
a different call so good taskmaster
actually be Hawkeye it's a pretty loose
connection but then fans spotted this
scene in the trailer that seemed to make
up for a real theory
oh he's using a bow he's associated with
Black Widow is this potentially how they
met is Hawkeye the one behind that mask
absolutely not remember taskmasters
whole shtick is copying other people's
moves the fact a taskmaster is using a
bow means that Hawkeye is probably in
the movie crafts just briefly in order
to teach taskmaster usage of the weapon
which in turn gives us a trailer shot
that gets us to all think that it might
actually be him
I mean Disney has misdirected us plenty
of times in recent history with their
trailers but think about it if ScarJo
was at least being partially honest when
she said that the movie takes place
between Civil War and infinity war well
there's no way that Hawkeye is the bad
guy Hawkeye as he might remember was
part of Captain America's team during
the Civil War
and as a result ended up in house arrest
which is why at the beginning of endgame
we see him in an ankle monitor now has
established an ant-man - these monitors
are easy enough to slip off but pulling
the same move twice seems pretty cheap
for the MCU besides what mission could
possibly be so important to Clint that
he 1 escapes his confines two changes
his entire appearance and three tries to
kill one of his best friends all before
calming down with his family and then
doing it all over again an end game it's
just a really muddled unclear story arc
also this one be the first time Hawkeye
was used as the bad guy and Marvel's
been pretty upfront about avoiding that
pitfall again done the whole mind
control thing no fan no after looking at
the evidence
taskmaster isn't just some new villain
of the week and he isn't Hawkeye but I
do believe that he's an old friend who
turned evil I also believe that this he
is actually a she my theory is that
taskmaster by the end of the movie will
be revealed to be her this one sitting
at the table Melina Bostic off
yep the one with the killer comedy line
from the trailer is gonna end up being
our villain it's also why all the
trailers are trying their darndest to
misdirect you who the heck is that guy
that's not a guy in etosha but Disney is
trying their darndest to get us to think
that it is no let me back up a bit and
give you some history on milena Vostok
off and why she's likely to be this
film's big bad in the comics Laura
Molina appears in the marvel fanfare
series where she's shown growing up in
the same training program as Natasha and
the movie seems to keep this continuity
in place together
however Melina is not quite as skilled
as Natasha and this too seems to be
canon in the MCU your braixen only the
breakable ones you're made of Marvel in
fact in the comics having to live in the
shadow of the Black Widow causes Molina
to develop a deep hatred for Natasha
eventually she leaves the surface of
Russian becomes a freelance assassin by
the name Iron Maiden where one of our
targets is you guessed it Black Widow
herself now clearly Iron Maiden and
taskmaster are two different characters
in the comics but if you look at their
abilities they're actually fairly
similar Molina is a master martial
artist master assassin master spy and
weapons expert basically everything you
need taskmaster to be heck you would
barely even need to change their
costumes hood check bodysuit check mask
done additionally Tony masters in the
comics injects himself with a knockoff
of the super serum that created Captain
America and in turn becomes taskmaster
Molina
it seems may be involved in a similar
kind of experiment she's also involved
in some quite complicated scientific
research which is at the heart of the
film story given the Super Soldier Serum
prevalence in the MCU so far it's
certainly not out of the question that
Molina could simply gain all her powers
from the serum after failing the Black
Widow program enough times she's been
cycled through the Red Room Black Widow
program five times there's also the
surprising bit of physical evidence in
fact the whole thing that got me started
on this theory in the first place is
this shot from the trailer here David
Harper's red Guardian has taken on
taskmaster and hand hand combat red
Guardian goes in for the headbutt and
you
see quite clearly that he has itself
some height on taskmaster in real life
david harbour is 6 foot 3 inches tall
well rachel weisz the one who plays
milena basta cough is 5 foot 6 inches
that would explain to us how red
guardian could have himself nearly a
full head of height over taskmaster
lastly though let's talk about the
family elements of this movie red
guardian specifically calls Melina
Yelena and Natasha family in the trailer
Gimli big together but by endgame we
know that this family no longer exists I
just have nothing and then I got this
this is John his family man Marvel made
me need to start adding spoiler warnings
to your trailers but this means that by
the end of Black Widow the other members
of Natasha's quote/unquote family here
are either gonna wind up dead or no
longer on friendly terms
we know Yelena is likely to take over
the mantle of Black Widow for The
Avengers in the main line MCU movies
going forward because well you know
Natasha is dead and because Black Widow
is scar Joe's final required movie in
her contract also also we know this
because something very similar happened
to her in the comics so this right here
my friends is gonna be the face of our
new Black Widow for the next generation
of movies that's pretty solidly in place
Red Guardian meanwhile is likely gonna
die because well we don't see him coming
out of any Doctor Strange portals at the
end of endgame I mean way to not show up
for the party in Earth's biggest battle
you goon which again leaves us alone
with Melina who you know would have had
a falling out of the family if she went
around trying to kill everyone makes
those Christmas get-togethers really
awkward
no I know what I'm suggesting here would
be a big shift in Marvel more but then
again this wouldn't be the first time
that Marvel swapped a character's name
or even their gender it's also something
Disney in 2020 would totally do after
years of people questioning the MCU for
a lack of female representation for them
getting made fun of of letting Wonder
Woman get to at first to basically have
Black Widow be females are strong the
movie is totally unbranded Tasha
unmasking taskmaster to reveal that whoa
girls can be super cool villains too who
are strong and independent that would
just be a big twist but it would also be
a strong message moment that Disney
won't
pass so when you look at all the
evidence we get ourselves a pretty
complete picture of what this movie is
gonna wind up being and appearance by
Hawkeye visit to Budapest chased by
General Ross of passing of the torch to
Yelena as the new Black Widow and the
betrayal of a family member when it's
revealed that under the mast
taskmaster was Melina the whole time
clearly I got that right that's why
you're not answering my questions get on
that Internet get on that but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and
subscribe to have all of Marvel's new
movies spoiled for you by hardcore
research induction sharing with a friend
and show them how smart and cultured the
stuff you watch online is where heck you
know what just subscribe so you can rub
it in my face when the movie comes out
and I'm completely wrong about
everything I predict it any way you
slice it you should just subscribe the
buzz on screen right now I've been Matt
Pat and I'll see you all next week